- Halloween is a big
time of the year, right?
For both of you.
- Always has been.
- Yeah!
- [Kelly] Do you like dressing up?
- Do you dress up?
- No, you know what?
- [Kelly] What?
- I started acting so young,
and they pay me to dress up.
- [Kelly] Okay, I get that.
- And so,
on Halloween I...
- But you should just go as...
- Every once,
I do have, I must admit,
I do have an Ice Cream Man costume.
- [Kelly] Oh no!
- That I break out.
- [Kelly] Okay.
Is this from the film?
Because that's scary.
What does the ice cream man sound like?
And I'm afraid to ask,
'cause I'm going home alone tonight.
(audience laughing)
- The ice cream man.
- [Kelly] Gosh!
No!
No, no, no.
- Happy day!
- No! Oh my Gosh.
- A little movie that I worked on in 1993.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Ron] It has cult status.
- [Clint] It has cult status,
and I play this wicked ice cream man that,
- [Kelly] Scary!
- chops up people and animals,
and puts them in the ice cream.
- Keep talking about it,
it's very very uplifting.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- Well, Halloween has
always been great for me.
Speaking of my parents,
I remember in the beginning
they didn't have much money,
but the first Halloween I really remember,
I was four,
and my dad made me
a knight in shining armor outfit,
but he got some boxes
from the grocery store,
spray-painted it silver,
and kind of cut them out
and set them over me,
but the last Halloween that I actually
went out on,
I was 16,
and I still dressing up,
- [Kelly] (chuckling)
- and trying to get free candy.
And it was actually,
- [Kelly] As you do.
(audience chuckling)
- It was actually the night
before my first date with Cheryl,
who's now my wife.
We're coming up on 51 years ago.
(audience awes)
- [Kelly] Wow!
(audience clapping)
- [Ron} Yeah.
- [Kelly] Congratulations!
- [Ron] Yeah, thank you.
- [Kelly] That's really
hard to do you know?
- We talk about straddling your future,
and your childhood.
- [Clint] What did you
dress up that year as?
- A ghoul.
I was a karate,
I was a black belt ghoul.
- [Kelly] Wait!
No, no.
You were a karate ghoul?
(chuckling)
- Karate ghoul.
I had a gi and a belt,
and then green circles.
- [Kelly] Not just a ghoul,
you were a ninja ghoul
- I was a ninja ghoul.
- [Kelly] Love it!